everyone remembers the first rhythm game
weather was mimicking the smooth flow of
crap of the rapper stepping alongside
their favorite dance dance revelution
song or even smacking a pair of bongos
and donkey konga we all share those fond
memories of nailing that perfect string
of notes and with the crowd behind us
cheering us on whether it was virtual or
real life those games gave us all a
sense of accomplishment the genre
enjoyed a moderate amount of success
thanks in part to konami x' line of
arcade games but it wasn't until 2005
when guitar hero came along that rhythm
games really struck a chord with gamers
and began receiving worldwide attention
yes by the way that pun was intended and
while the big franchises like guitar
hero and rock band enjoyed the better
half of a decade as the best-selling
games in the world rhythm games start
falling victim to a similar problem with
the introduction of the guitar shaped
controllers it started becoming a race
to see who could emulate the rock star
experience the best it started with
guitars slowly expanded into full bands
then DJ turntables and before you knew
it we were up tore armpits and plastic
instruments sure this might not sound
too bad and might even be considered
beneficial that the genre was expanding
beyond this mostly Japanese player base
but the saturation of rhythm games
brought about a sense of obsolescence
with controllers piling up in people's
closets as each new iteration of a
series brought with it an updated
peripheral I mean admit it there's a
dusty plastic controller somewhere in
your house that's just begging to be
played with by 2010 almost five years at
the top of the gaming world rhythm games
finally started to falter sales
plummeted and they went from being the
hottest games on the planet - just
another expensive peripheral filled
gimmicky genre the studio's attempted to
win back fans by honing in on certain
demographics of music lovers but it was
still the same base game and they
weren't offering as many unique
experiences anymore it almost started to
feel like developers were losing sight
of what made rhythm games great in the
first place
but all of that might be changing it's
now 2016 and the state of VR gaming in
particular has led developers to try and
provide more immersive experiences to
the public and to of the releases for
the PlayStation VR just so happen to be
rythm games there's thumper a game where
you play a space beetle speeding down a
track hitting jumps and curves to the
beat and then there's res infinite a
remake of the original 2001 psychedelic
shooter but which also includes a brand
new area designed specifically for VR
now gameplay wise these two couldn't
play more differently thumper is a
pulse-pounding rhythm violence game as
they call it requiring lightning quick
reactions to succeed while res infinite
is more of a relaxing experience letting
you create your own beats and allowing
the music to just wash over you
but if there's one thing that they do
share aside from the trapeze space like
settings it's their ability to entrace
the player in the music and the visuals
even though they can both be played on a
normal television they are two games
whose existence is amplified by the use
of virtual reality with the VR headset
on and with sensory immersion in full
effect
you are immediately pulled into the
game's world bobbing your head to the
beat moving your body in tune with the
music they may be the only game so far
where I felt the VR technology to be the
engrossing experience it's promised to
be yes the prospect of VR being the new
guiding light for rhythm games might be
hard to stomach considering the platform
is still at this point in its infancy
but it's also exciting to dream about
all the new games that we can immerse
ourselves in and all the new ways that
we can achieve that same feeling that we
had when we first picked up a guitar
hero controller and this is why I feel
like VR could be the thing to resurrect
the rhythm game genre on their own
rhythm games can be tense what Phil
d'affaires
but the pairing of VR simply adds to
that visceral satisfying high that we
all crave while playing these games the
critical success of both res Infinite
and thumper prove that can be done well
but more importantly they've proven that
you don't need to be playing an
instrument or even getting down on the
dance floor to be absorbed by the music
what they've done is essentially widen
the playing field with what's possible
in VR and rhythm games and honestly I
can't wait to see what the future holds
for both
what do you think about the marriage
between rhythm games and VR which series
would you like to see most on the
platform
I'm personally holding out for a new
parappa but let me know in the comments
what you think and thanks for watching